if they were worried about the legal sex
workers wouldn't they have done this in
all of the counties
why only those two counties i don't
think that they were expecting to find a
legal sex worker that would be willing
to go in front of the camera and refute
each and every nonsense point they have
made can you back this up yes 110
if we lose this ability to work legally
we will lose
everything wow
it sure as heck weren't ready for me
prostitution is defined as the practice
or occupation of engaging in sexual
activity with someone for payment
this type of sex work has been around
for a long time in many parts of the
world this is illegal and often done
underground in the u.s however
there is one state where it's allowed in
nevada brothels can operate
in counties with less than 700 000
residents but today
in the 2018 midterm elections one of
these counties is risking losing this
privilege as they are voting on whether
brothels should be banned or remain
legal today we are traveling to lyon
county nevada to spend election night
with two sex workers who risk losing
their jobs if brothels are to be banned
[Music]
as soon as we arrive we notice that
people are talking about this
maybe two months ago i picked up a lady
and she comes
four times a month to work for rent
yeah for what she's making because there
was a demand for me yeah yeah
let me see how things play out though
are we here don't get the outside of
their house
how are you how are you i'm in um alice
is actually recording on youtube
i think that's all we have for this week
thank you so much for once again joining
me for another coffee with alice so good
to finally meet you
so i'm here right now because i want to
be here for the election
i live out of state and fly in here to
work
it was the only option for me
i have kids i don't want to get arrested
i don't want my work to be criminalized
i want channels through which i can work
that provide me protections and after
doing a lot of research it really
came to be that the brothels here were
the only option
i'm an independent contractor i went to
the sheriff's department had a full
background check
i was fingerprinted i have a sheriff's
card i go to the doctor every week to
get tested
every month blood and every week we have
a cervical swab
and we can't work unless we pass a test
all production is used
during every act condom for everything
dental dam for oral sex
you know we have panic buttons in our
room we have security on staff we have
cameras
when prostitution is illegal girls die
they get raped they get robbed
they suffer violence from pimps other
girls there's not money
and resources for every working girl to
be able to
get tested and know she's safe or access
to
condoms and protection there's many
girls that would be forced out
to work illegally if we lose this
ability to work legally we will lose
everything
i'm alice little and i am a legal sex
worker
at the moonlight bunny ranch
so today we get to find out the results
of many many hard months of campaigning
and letting people know who we are and
what the legal brothels are actually
about
the biggest misconception about sex
workers
is that we sell sex what we do is offer
intimacy
a service much in the same way that a
mental health professional
provides a service to the community a
mental health professional addresses
mental health needs
a legal sex worker addresses sex and
intimacy needs
during that time i essentially step into
an ersatz relationship with my guest
we hold hands we touch we kiss
and we do a lot more than just having
sex i
look at what we have done for lyon
county the jobs we've provided the tax
dollars the revenue
and how that spread back into the
economy i think that it would be really
incredible to see
what that benefit could be for other
counties
much in the same way that we're taking
tax dollars and revenue funds
from medical marijuana and using that
towards our schools
why don't we take the money from
legalized sex work and move that forward
in the community
to continue to benefit and grow our
communities
i guess the biggest question that at
least we have is
when did this petition come about and
who is pushing it
so the real issue started when dennis
entered politics
dennis was running as a libertarian for
state assembly
and he did not win that year because the
county is so
red essentially he was told the only way
he would be able to win
is to run as a republican at this point
he had to win twice first in the primary
against
james oskerson and then in the general
election
which happens today at that time
jason guinaso forms a pack etac which
stands for end trafficking and
prostitution
and they pushed the petition both in the
lion county
but also in another county too they
started a petition
in nye county dennis
owns brothels in only two of the
counties that it is
legal interestingly enough this group
only pushed petitions in the two
counties that dennis owned braupos in
right so if they were worried about the
legal sex workers
wouldn't they have done this in all of
the counties why only those two counties
are they trying to save sex workers or
are they just trying to put dennis out
of business
what is the relation between the lawyer
and dennis's opponent jason guenazzo
works for hutchinson's law firm and as
we know
mark hutchinson is the close political
ally for james oskarson
who dennis was running against for
office
because of that ally ship it's entirely
probable
that jason guinaso was asked to file
this petition
on behalf of oskarson in an attempt to
distract dennis from his campaign
jason is the one who triggered the
petition in the first place
he helped them organize he got the
paperwork in place
and then pushed the issue forward
thankfully the night county petition
failed to receive enough signatures so
they dropped it entirely dropped it
but what happened in lyon county is
really unfortunate
fearing that they would manage to get
enough signatures
the commissioners offered to put an
advisory question
on the ballot nothing happens based off
of the vote
it's just pretty much to measure public
opinion right historically they always
go with what the popular voters
they've always gone with the popular
vote dennis did in fact
defeat oscarson in the primary
dennis passed away just a couple of
weeks ago
so with dennis now being gone
what does that mean they are still
pushing at this point dennis's name is
still on the ballot
he very well could win that seat
[Music]
posthumously
[Music]
so we've been here for about two hours
now at the watch party the polls closed
what two hours ago two hours ago i'm so
confident that we're gonna be okay
but not knowing is just kind of eating
away it's hard
it's really hard we wanna know we just
wanna know already being here now as
it's happening
is actually really surreal and kind of
scary and seeing how close
all the other elections coming through
have been
um it's really nerve-wracking and i want
to believe so hard that it's going to
work out
partial results
[Music]
you can't really get caught up in
judging what people do or why they do it
because life is tough sometimes yeah and
we all have the same uh
cards dealt to us so i don't judge
anything or anybody
you